Welcome back to the Georgia Tech
Metropolitan Opera where we will be
singing about Computer Vision for
the rest of the day.
Because I'm, like, going nuts already
recording all these lectures, and
I have to do something differently.
However, as my children will tell you,
my singing about anything
is generally a bad idea.
So, let's chat instead.
So last time we were
talking about motion
this is within this general context.
And we talked about that,
if you're looking locally,
you can't actually tell
the direction of motion of a pixel.
And that was referred to
as this aperture problem.
Remember this little demo, where we said
that even though the actual thing is
moving sideways and down a little bit,
you see it as moving upwards.
Because the only part that
you can see that edge,
all you can tell is the direction of
motion in the direction of the gradient.
And we showed that here,
that that was derived from our
brightness constraint equations.
Where we showed that the u,
v dotted with the gradient
has to be the negative of I t,
that's what that equation says.
But an UV,
any motion who's component perpendicular
to the edge along the gradient is
the same, would be an acceptable u, v.
So we needed some
additional constraints.
So, last time we talked about int
introducing some global requirement.
We talked about a smoothness
constraint that would allow us to
optimize the solution
over the entire image.
But today,
we're going to look at more local and
frankly, much more effective or
certainly more commonly used methods.